PROVIDED.
>> WOW.
SO MUCH MORE INFORMATION.
YOU LOOK AROUND AND SAY COULD
THERE HAVE BEEN STOPPED.
MARK IS WITH US A FORMER
DETECTIVE OF THE LAND.
LAPD AND WE HAVE AN FBI NATIONAL
SPOKESPERSON.
MARK, PEOPLE SAY HOW COULD THEY
MISS THESE SIGNS?
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE CASE
HERE.
DO YOU?
>> NO, I DON'T.
THERE ARE MANY TIMES WHEN
SOMEBODY DOES DROP THE BALL, BUT
THIS IS NOT ONE OF THEM.
IN FACT, I THINK THEY WENT WAY
OUT OF THEIR WAY WHEN THEY
CONTACTED HER AT 1:42 IN THE
MORNING AND CONTACTED HER
FATHER.
39-YEAR-OLD FEMALES THAT ARE IN
CONTROL OF THEIR FACULTIES ARE
NOT MISSING.
SHE KNOWS WHERE SHE IS.
SHE KNOWS WHAT SHE IS DOING.
SHE CAN LEAVE NETIME SHE WANTS.
I DON'T BELIEVE THEY DID
ANYTHING WRONG.
>> JOHN, AS YOU SEE SOMEBODY, WE
DON'T USUALLY SEE FEMALES.
NO HISTORY OF VIOLENCE.
HAD A GUN LEGALLY.
FOUND SLEEPING IN HER CAR.
DO YOU ANY SIGNS THEY WOULD
MISS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THE POLICE MADE AN INQUIRY.
TO PICK UP THE PHONE AND CALL
THE FAMILY ON SOMEBODY WHO IS AN
ADULT TO REASSURE THEM THAT SHE
IS OKAY, LIKEWISE, IF THE FAMILY
HAD ANY KNOWLEDGE OF THE WEAPON,
I HAVE NOT HEARD A WORD ABOUT
THAT YET.
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS.
MARK.
MY SENSE IS WATCHING THESE
VIDEOS, HEARING THAT SHE WAS
PROTESTING IN FEBRUARY WITH
youTUBE TAKING HER STUFF DOWN.
I SENSE THE FAMILY KNOWS A LOT
MORE ABOUT HOW UNHINGED THIS
SHOOTER WAS.
DO YOU GET THAT SENSE?
>> I DO.
I THINK THE FAMILY KNOWS A LOT
LIKE MAYBE MANY FAMILIES THAT
HAVE PROBLEMS WITH SOMEBODY
INSIDE THEIR FAMILY.
THEY WANT TO KEEP THAT CLOSE TO
THE VEST AND NOT EXPRESS THEIR
FEARS.